New Hampshire's on the line Sandra's
with us I Sandra how are you I'm well
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up I am fairly new to your
program we probably discovered you in
the spring my husband and I and I got
the Total Money Makeover I read it my
husband and I are completely on started
working on our debt snowball we're up to
baby step two started with about a
hundred and sixteen thousand got
ourselves down to so far a hundred
thousand and progress yeah very good
progress and then September first my
husband got a phone call that he is out
of a job and I'm a stay-at-home mom we
have four kids he is still employed
through the end of November and if he
stays through the end of November if
Cade through the end of December but
this was a completely unexpected
blindsided thing and what kind of debt
is the hundred thousand we have a pool
loan we had just put in a pool we have
an equity loan we have some credit card
debt and I would say that makes up the
majority of it the kraaho we also have
we also have some medical debt and we
all don't have I'm sorry Carlos we have
a lease but we are other vehicle is paid
off okay and what does he make now
well his salary is 179 not including you
know bonuses Wow
what's he doing he is in Technical Sales
basically data security hardware okay
well obviously it's a highly specialized
ultra high paying position I'm thinking
he should be able to land that again
true and and he believed me is turning
over every stone and and exhausting
every connection and and even had
hundreds recruiters who have pursued him
in the past
so now that were
month into it we're just trying to look
ahead and say okay what do we do because
even though we are confident that this
is at God's direction and we know he's
our provider and we know he has
something in store we don't know his
hunting right so what I loved is I'm a
push stop on everything I'm gonna pay no
extra I'm gonna pay as little as I can
possibly pay and see how big a pile of
cash I can build and that's your that's
your you know your umbrella because the
storms coming right and then so we're
not doing Total Money Makeover we're not
doing death snowball well you know we're
gonna pay minimum payments minimum
everything I can pay put off anything I
can put off because we're gonna hoard
cash for a little while
the Bible says in the house of the wise
our stores of choice food and oil you've
got a storm coming and we're gonna
batten down the hatches and get ready
now we think this is all gonna work out
you and I and and I think you're right
and I got especially given his situation
and what he does I think you'll land
something and and likely we'll end up
with a higher income as a result it
won't surprise me at all I've heard that
story many times over the years so if
that happens then we just take that pile
of cash and throw it back at the debts
and we go back at it again right but
until then we're gonna pile up
every nickel we can pile up we're not
doing anything if you had a vacation
plan cancel it you don't need to be
going out to eat you guys need to be
really you know beans and rice rice and
beans completely scorched earth
lifestyle piling up cash piling up cash
piling up cash as high as you can pile
it and that that's going to give you the
the ability to weather this storm and
turn the corner on this without having
to get into retirement plans or
something else and start getting
penalized and all that kind of stuff to
keep your house and all that kind of
junk so you just don't want to go there
but but you know the bigger you get
there well you'll just deal with it when
you get there you may have themselves
the question is what is my what is our
step like let's say you know God is
working on something but it doesn't come
through until March I mean do we do we
go to our 401k well they won't know how
we'll pay the mortgage yeah yeah you may
have to
I hope not okay but you may have to and
you may take some penalties and some
losses there preferably not and
preferably you can do some other things
consulting in other things in backfill
with some income until he lands the big
job if it's till March before he lands
the big job and it might not be that
it's zero income it might just be real
thin so you just back into it that way
but let's pile up as much as we can pile
up and get ready for this and I think
he's gonna land something let me know
how it turns out this is the Dave Ramsey
show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you